welcome to the jungle I'm in Hawaii
chatting with Dwayne Johnson Kevin Hart
Jack Black and Nick Jonas on the new
adventure of Jumanji you know we go way
back we got a thing first I got to see
the tattoo in its complete oh yeah oh
yeah do you think of it something fresh
that's all we need to know is what Jack
thinks of the tattoos that's it is that
not this side I'm just seeing what I see
right now uh two molars on a small of
his back he said yeah that one that one
actually inside it's a mana thing which
you know spirit and power but yeah we
got some our world what inspired the
name uh you know I wish I can say I have
something doing in our business my wife
my wife she knows everything
that is my a honey whatever you want
whatever you want stop
maybe Kevin's little guy can continue
the franchise for years to come
posing in Hawaii the cast really had
become family during their Jumanji
adventure it pushed each other to find
their inner 16 year olds especially Jack
Black we got sucked into Jumanji and
we've become the avatars we chose so
that means Bethany the fact that you
guys are playing 16 year olds you know
you I'm sure because such a mature men
well this will mature teenage girl Matt
I think you were supposed to be a girl
like I like can't even with this place
did you guys have to dig deep to get to
that point and take these characters on
I mean I wasn't like method actor a
always a 16 year old it I turned it on
and off like a switch like a light
switch yeah it was just fun you know I
was a fun character to play we on set so
as we were rehearsing we'd rehearse
before we started to shoot before we
even shot a frame of the movie we'd
rehearse and we would hearse in
character all of us and Jack would hold
back and he wasn't giving us all the
character yet he wasn't being the
sixteen-year-old girl yet understand
that it was saying it up very first take
on set here in Hawaii we're all doing
the scenes first time he starts talking
as a 16 year old girl that was so real I
mean recent that we knew it we knew game
over removing all the pieces of puzzle
and all came together
[Music]